الآن لولا هي واحدة من تلك الوجهات
التي يمكنك أن تقرأ عنها ، يمكنك
التعرف عليها ولكن حتى
تزورها بالفعل ، من الصعب أن
تفهم أن
لولا هي مثال جيد
لوجهة سياحية ريفية ، إنها
مجتمع صغير في منطقة هي  حجم
بلجيكا في المقام الأول ، كان جميع السكان من
مزارعي التمر لأن سيارة الليموزين هي
واحة بها مليوني نخلة
أثناء زيارتك للوجهة ، أحد
الأشياء التي ستدركها
وتجربها هو أنك تعرف نوعًا ما
عددًا صغيرًا جدًا من  الأشخاص معك ، إنها ليست
وجهة رئيسية ، إنها
وجهات سياحية فردية جدًا
مخصصة لتنمية السياحة الريفية
ولكنها أيضًا تشارك
المجتمع المحلي بطريقة تجعلهم جزءًا من
القصة ويتفاعلون مع
الزوار بطريقة أصيلة للغاية
منذ حدوث الطمع ، رأينا المزيد من
الأفراد المهتمين بتجربة Escapist
حيث يمكنهم نوعًا من الاسترخاء
والراحة وإعادة الشحن ، لذا فإن كل
ضغوط الحياة اليومية صحيحة ،
وما فعلناه في alula هو أننا وجدنا
Adventure منتجًا  بالنسبة لهم للاستمتاع
بمنتج العافية المتاح
كطريقة للاستمتاع بالبيئات الطبيعية التي
لدينا من
حيث من هم زوارنا 69
من جميع أنحاء
المملكة العربية السعودية و 31 من
الأسواق الدولية من الواضح أن أسواق دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
مهمة جدًا  الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية أو
أوروبا أو السوقان الأساسيان الآخران
في آسيا تلحق بالركب ، لذلك نشهد
اهتمامًا جيدًا على مستوى العالم أه في
وقت قصير نشهد الكثير من
الاهتمامات القوية للغاية جمهورنا المستهدف الأول
هو المملكة العربية السعودية